WE  WE ARE ALREADY LAUGHING.
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING HE NEVER
DIRECTED HIS FORMER PERSONAL
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN TO BREAK
THE LAW.
THE EXCLUSIVE FOX NEWS INTERVIEW
AND JUST A MOMENT.
FIRST, IN THE WAKE OF ALL THE
MILLER PROBE DEVELOPMENT,
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO BEAT THE
IMPEACHMENT DRUM AND PREDICT THE
PRESIDENT'S DEMISE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THIS PRESIDENT
IS DANGEROUS.
I THINK HE HAS UNDERMINED OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I THINK HE'S ALIGNED HIMSELF
WITH THE ENEMY, WITH PUTIN.
HE LOVES DICTATORS.
I BELIEVE HE CERTAINLY QUALIFIES
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
WE MAY NEVER GET IT DONE, AND
MAYBE DEMOCRATS FEAR THAT
SOMEHOW IF WE MOVE TO IMPEACH
HIM, MAYBE HIS BASE WILL GROW
LARGER.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> I'M PREPARED TO SAY SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER SAID.
THE WRITING IS ON THE WALL.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN, AND
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE END
FOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> Dana: THIS COMES AS TRUMP
DEFENDS HIMSELF AGAINST
ACCUSATIONS OF ANY WRONGDOING
WITH MICHAEL COHEN.
>> I NEVER DIRECTED HIM TO DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
HE DID SOME BAD THINGS UNRELATED
TO ME.
MAY BE RELATED TO HIS OTHER
CLIENTS.
IT WASN'T HIS ONLY CLIENT.
THEY SAY IT'S NOT A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
OR IT'S NOT EVEN UNDER CAMPAIGN
FINANCE.
IF IT WAS, IT'S NOT EVEN A
VIOLATION.
NUMBER THREE, IT'S A CIVIL
MATTER.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD A REALLY BIG
ONE WITH TEN TIMES MORE MONEY,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, HE PAID A
FINE.
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS EITHER COHEN
OR THE PROSECUTORS, IN ORDER TO
EMBARRASS ME, SAID LISTEN, I
MAKING THIS DEAL FOR REDUCED
TIME AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
DO ME A FAVOR.
PUT THESE TWO CHARGES ON WHO
THEY ARE NOT CRIMINAL CHARGES.
>> Dana: WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
IT AROUND THE TABLE.
EMILY, LET'S START WITH YOU.
DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL ELITES, THE
ESTABLISHMENT, THEY KNOW THE
POLITICAL AND PERILS OF GOING
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
BUT THE BASE, THEY REALLY WANT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BE IMPEACH.
THEY ARE KIND OF BETWEEN A ROCK
AND A HARD PLACE.
>> Emily: WHAT I DON'T KNOW IS
HOW YOU CAN RECONCILE IT.
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT I
THINK SHOULD BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND EFFORT
AND COST IT TAKES.
TO WHAT END?
WE KNOW THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
ACQUITTAL IN THE SENATE.
THE CALL TODAY FROM
REPRESENTATIVE SCHIFF ABOUT WE
SHOULD AMEND OR MAKE AN
EXCEPTION TO THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL'S DECISION, I READ THAT
DECISION.
IT AFFIRMS A 1973 DECISION.
GOING BACK TO "THE FEDERALIST"
PAPERS.
AND CLINTON V JONES.
THE GREATER TRAVESTIES THAT WE
ARE HAVING LEGISLATORS OFFER THE
KIND OF INFLUENCE ON THE DOJ,
ONE ISN'T THE ENTIRE
CONVERSATION THIS WHOLE TIME AND
ALL OF THEIR SHOUTING ABOUT
SEPARATIONS OF POWERS?
THAT LEVEL OF INFLUENCE TO ME
AND VENDETTA AND WASTING MY
TAXPAYER DOLLARS, THAT'S WHAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Dana: I LIKE THE HAND
GESTURES.
BRING MORE OF IT.
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING
TO HAPPEN BETWEEN THE PUSH AND
PULL?
IT'S LIKE THE BASIS PUSHING
FORWARD.
THEY WANT THIS IMPEACHMENT.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI, LET'S TAP THE
BRAKES ON THAT.
CAN SHE WITHHOLD THE FORCES?
>> Juan: YEAH.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS VERY
REALISTIC AT THIS POINT.
PEOPLE LIKE STENY HOYER, THE
NUMBER TWO, THEY SAY LISTEN.
LET'S WAIT ON MUELLER.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE HAS.
BUT IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, A LOT OF THE
IRAQI PEOPLE THINK WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON IS PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS
AND THEY WORRY ABOUT IT NOT ONLY
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE CONGRESSMAN
FROM WASHINGTON SAID THERE HAD
BEEN 36 PEOPLE INDICTED.
THREE PEOPLE NOW HAVE PRISON
TERMS.
YOU START TO THINK WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
WHY IS HE SO FRIENDLY WITH
PUTIN?
IS IT A DISTRACTION?
EVEN FOR REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE
STARTING TO SAY I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE WALL
ET CETERA.
I THINK THE KEY WAS HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM PEOPLE WHO
GET IN TROUBLE, SPECIFICALLY
MICHAEL COHEN.
A LONG TIME AGO HE SAID I DIDN'T
KNOW ONE THING ABOUT THESE
PAYMENTS.
NO PAYMENT WAS MADE.
THEN JULIANA SAID THE PAYMENT
WAS MADE AND TRUMP REPAID COHEN.
NOW YOU HAVE TRUMP SAYING HE'S A
LOW LEVEL EMPLOYEE.
I THINK HE WAS A P.R. GUY.
>> Dana: P.R. PEOPLE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> Juan: HE DESCRIBED COHEN AS
A LAWYER WHO SHOULD KNOW.
NOW HE'S A P.R. GUY.
>> Dana: JESSE, LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
DURING THE INTERVIEW TODAY.
I THINK YOU MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN THIS.
>> I SEE THIS ON THE FRONT PAGE
OF "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
WHICH JUST CAME OUT.
LOOK.
TRUMP DIDN'T VIOLATE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS.
TRUMP X AID.
>> I INTERVIEWED HIM ON MY
PROGRAM THE OTHER DAY.
>> MICHAEL COHEN PLED GUILTY.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW THAT GUY,
HANS VON SPAKOVSKY.
I'M GOING TO MAKE JUAN READ IT.
I'M GOING TO TEST YOU TOMORROW.
OBVIOUSLY THE FEC, I'M NOT GOING
TO BORE YOU WITH IT BECAUSE IT
IS VERY GRANULAR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT KNOW A LOT
ABOUT CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW DO
NOT BELIEVE THIS PAYMENT
VIOLATED ANY LAW WHATSOEVER.
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT THE
PROSECUTORS?
>> Jesse: WHICH PROSECUTORS?
>> Juan: NEW YORK SOUTHERN
DISTRICT.
>> Jesse: SOME PROSECUTORS ARE
TRYING TO LINK THE PRESIDENT'S
OTHER CRIMES THAT COHEN
COMMITTED.
THE HARASSMENT THING I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING WITH FIRE.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED WITH
KAVANAUGH.
THERE WAS SO MUCH INJUSTICE WITH
KAVANAUGH AND SO MUCH
UNFAIRNESS.
IT WAS SO OUT-OF-BOUNDS BUT
REALLY ACTIVATED THE REPUBLICAN
BASE.
IF THE REPUBLICANS GOING INTO
2020 SEE PARTISAN PROSECUTORS
AND MAXINE AND HER BANDITS GOING
AFTER THIS PRESIDENT AND A LOT
OF SHADOWY PEOPLE WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO TAKE AWAY A
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
FROM OUR REPUBLIC, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO FEEL ROBBED.
IF PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEIR VOTES
ARE BEING ROBBED, THEY ARE GOING
TO TURN OUT SO HEAVILY AND
THERE'S GOING TO BE SO MUCH
BACKLASH AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT,
IT'S GOING TO BE ASTRONOMICAL.
ANOTHER FORM OF HARASSMENT NOW,
LETITIA JAMES, I BELIEVE SHE'S
THE LOCAL AG HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
STATE.
JUST ELECTED.
SHE SAYS I'M GOING TO
INVESTIGATE TRUMP TOWER.
I'M GOING TO INVESTIGATE THE
TRUMP COMPANY.
TRUMP FOUNDATION.
WHAT CRIME IS SHE INVESTIGATING?
SHE IS JUST INVESTIGATING
EVERYTHING THAT SAYS TRUMP
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THERE IS A
CRIME.
THAT'S NOT HOW PROSECUTORS, NOT
HOW ATTORNEY GENERALS ARE
SUPPOSED TO OPERATE.
THAT'S OUTSIDE THE LAW.
>> Dana: GREG, WE HAVE COVERED
A LOT OF GROUND BUT WE HAVE TO
GET YOUR TAKE.
>> Greg: JUAN IS NOT CORRECT.
AMERICA DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS.
COLLUSION ALWAYS POLES THE
LOWEST IN TERMS OF CONCERN.
AMERICA DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE COHEN.
THESE PEOPLE HAPPEN TO BE ON THE
PERIPHERY.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT IS THE
ECONOMY, JOBS, THEIR FAMILY.
NATIONAL SECURITY, SAFETY,
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS
STUFF, THE SAME WAY THEY DIDN'T
CARE WHEN THEY WENT AFTER
BILL CLINTON.
WHAT DID THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS DUE TO BILL CLINTON?
IT MADE AMERICA LOVE HIM MORE
BECAUSE AMERICA LOVES A BAD BOY.
IF TRUMP FACES IMPEACHMENT, HE
BECOMES AN ORANGE FONZIE.
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WANT
IMPEACHMENT, JUST MAKE -- ASK
TRUMP TO WORK HALF AS MUCH.
YOU WANT HIM GONE BECAUSE HE
WORKS TOO HARD.
SO WHY DOESN'T HE WORK HALF AS
MUCH?
ONE TRUMP DAYS IS SEVEN DAYS IN
DEMOCRAT DAYS.
THAT'S WHY THE MEDIA AND WHY THE
DEMOCRATS LOOK SO EXHAUSTED.
HE'S WORKING THEM INTO THE
GROUND.
THE COMPROMISES DONALD TRUMP
DON'T WORK SO MUCH.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT SO HARD.
HE'S TAKEN A 16 DAY CHRISTMAS
HOLIDAY.
>> Greg: GOOD FOR HIM.
HE DOES FIVE THINGS IN THE DAY
WHEN PRESIDENTS USUALLY GET
AROUND TO ONE.
IMPEACH HIM.
WHAT DO YOU GET?
YOU GET PENCE.
PENCE IS SO CONSERVATIVE, HE
ONCE PAID OFF A WOMAN AFTER HE
SHOOK HER HAND.
YOU TRADE IN MR. RIGHT, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET MR. EVEN MORE
RIGHT.
THIS IS SUCH A TRAVESTY.